hello and welcome to my session about
zero effort analytical method validation
my name is jurgen fourgang and in the
next minutes i will show you
how this work flow can be implemented
selecting the ideal solution for today's
laboratories
this presentation will provide guidance
and show optimized workflows and tools
for selecting and implementing the ideal
method validation solution
that will save up to 70 percent of time
and cost
compared to performing the tasks
manually
as you can see the diagram 70 percent
can be saved
where the optimal workflow has been
implemented
what is important for the efficient
workflow we'll start with an overview
guidelines for method validation
analytical method validation work is
based on a variety of guidelines and
requirements
these guidelines define the basics of
validation work
the purpose the scope and what to do
we have lots of guidelines like ich
usp ep jp
dean iso fda and visa
and others
method validation work requires more
effort than ever
beginning with analytical and scientific
work
and even more reports and compliance
documentation
lots of paperwork reducing this work
and improving efficiency while ensuring
the highest level of documentation
quality
and data integrity is welcomed by both
qa and laboratory but how can this be
achieved
analytical method validation what do we
need for our work
the objective of the validation of an
analytical procedure
is to demonstrate that it is suitable
for its intended purpose
efficiency and data integrity are the
most important requirements for method
validation software solutions
but what does that mean and how can it
be achieved
first in terms of time from planning to
find a report
and second in terms of good and
compliant output
first efficiency in terms of time from
planning to final report
the workflow should be well defined
it is normally done in our sop document
easy to understand and easy to follow so
we need clear steps on the workflow
for creating a new project doing the
detailed planning and the project plan
entering our data either manually or by
using interfaces
and calculating and creating the final
result document
guided by wizards assistance and to-do
lists
so it's a very good idea to have a
software solution
with wizards and to-do lists that will
clearly offer what the next step would
be in the workflow
and eliminating the need to use
additional tools
no pocket calculator no excel no slide
rule
because all these external tools need to
be validated
and so in case you have one body data
tool
offering the complete workflow it is
good to stay with that tool
and to avoid aid external input
second efficiency in terms of good and
compliant output
a validated calculation framework is
mandatory
but we need more we need
result sets well-defined output with no
random changes
predefined layouts including your
corporate identity with logos
headers and cover pages predefined
summaries
that allow an easy summary of validation
projects main results
we need predefined formulas that can be
added to the report
to be much clearer how all these results
were
calculated but validation project should
not only contain calculations but all
data integrity related info
for full 21 civil party level compliance
data integrity full compliance to 2017
part 11 is mandatory
or to equivalent regulations like eu
gmp and x11 data protection can be
guaranteed by software access levels
by logins roles departments and check
some protected backend databases
like oracle or microsoft sql server
the whole workflow must be completely
tracked by means of
audit trades all activities in detail
as well as revision history both
searchable
and retrievable auditors have a very
close look on all aspects of electronic
data
so keep an eye on that it is very
important
21 cfr part 11. besides validation and
part 11 compliance certificates
a 21 cfr part 11 compliance response is
mandatory
this compliance response provides
detailed answers for the requirements of
part 11
it's a mandatory document when using a
software and regulated environments
it is part of your software
documentation as well as
iq and oq protocols and other quality
related paperwork
establishing an optimized workflow with
minimum effort
templates the key from optimized
workflow is predefining all
aspects of typical method validation
work by workflow templates
that reduce new projects to a few clicks
such templates follow your sops contain
typical workflows and workloads and
structure your tasks to optimize
efficiency and compliance communication
with your laboratory equipment
like cds lims ecm erp dms
should be automatic and easy with manual
intervention
limited to a minimum guidelines and
validation structure
guidelines are translated into
validation workload for example
checkpoints
to create and structure validation
projects
on the right side of the slide you can
see a typical validation project
it is organized as a hierarchical tree
with the name of the project on top
below that you can see the components or
chapters
and below them you can see the
individual checkpoints
the checkpoints have icons in front
which indicate
the status of the checkpoint it could be
unplanned planned containing data
or in case it's a traffic cloud symbol
it means
that acceptances were predefined
in the case of a red traffic light it
means that
at least one acceptance was not met and
green traffic light indicates
that everything is fine within this
checkpoint
testing workload your testing workload
is defined by your
accreditation authority customers sops
and your personal ambitions
in any case the testing workload must be
well-defined and not random
it must be clear why a specific workflow
as well as acceptance tracking has been
selected
this workflow definition is established
as a validation plan
that needs to be approved prior to
decoration start
custom workflows adopting
new or changed workflows should be as
easy as possible
graphical design tools business process
managers
allow user-designed workflows without
software modification
different projects require different
workflows that can be selected from
predefined designs more than result
calculation
documentation let's now focus on
documentation
method validation work is much more than
just calculating results
it is setting up your testing workload
both simple and flexible
with final documentation matching
customer expectations
as well as regulatory requirements
this requires a highly configurable and
powerful reporting solution
to create documentation templates for
all purposes
internal as well as official validation
reports
best practices important and frequently
used report elements should be available
for immediate usage
for example text blocks snippet
libraries
ease this process and guarantee good
reporting quality
this applies to headers approval
sections cover pages result acceptance
tables
and lots of other elements final
documentation
final method validation documentation
needs to be
easy to understand well structured
illustrated when necessary easily
summarized to get the main result
as you can see in these three examples
document transfer and protection fining
documents must follow established
standards for easy exchange
like pdfa standard and well protected by
secure algorithms
to be safe against external modification
integrate and embed your method
validation workflow into your lab
environment
interfacing your laboratory equipment
manual data input should be avoided
whenever possible
automatic transfer eliminates the need
to control and check manual inputs
all laboratory systems need to be
attached to your method validation
software like
cds chromatography data systems
lims lab information management system
erp enterprise resource planning
ecm enterprise content management
and dms document management system
interface workflow interfaces connect
your validation projects to external
data sources
these external sources can be easily
browsed
and the data used for your projects
data is automatically transferred
predefined workflows control data flow
and reduce time and eliminate input
errors
a typical workflow could be create
a new validation project connect it to a
data source
like cds lims erp or ecm
[Music]
assign and load the data and create the
final validation
report and export it in all the typical
formats like pdfa
when you're using that you will have a
highly integrated predefined workflow
that makes it easy to create a new
project
flexibility even a method validation
project based on a well-established
template
might need modifications for a specific
pending project
here we have three examples for that the
first one is a data input grid
with additional data columns the second
one
is a custom defined report output with a
detailed analysis of recovery data
and the third example is an additional
calculation script for having an
extended calculation workflow
project fine tuning while templates
define routine work it's critical to
allow flexibility for each new project
additional calculations graphics and
report extensions must be added easily
hence it is viable to allow fine-tuning
of your projects for specific purpose
for example different testing workflow
additional calculations or modified
layout
in any case such modifications must be
fully checked
the difference to the underlying
template explained
and justified in the validation plan
maximum level of data integrity
since your data is worth being protected
all this must be accompanied by a
maximum level of data integrity
which means strict access control
detailed traceability
version history and full 21 cfor part 11
compliance
centralized installations application
and database server
are strongly recommended to keep your
data safe and to ease application
rollouts and maintenance
insulation quantification must be
ensured by automated
iq and output processes
on the right side you see a typical
result of an iq
in that case 134 components were checked
for correct installation location
internal checksum
and version and there were no
information
nor warning the errors to be displayed
so the overall result was
installation quantification test passed
tools for qa and it admins and qa have
lots of requests for data integrity and
consistency checks
to be carried out on a regular basis
all these queries can be done based on
existing audit trade information
and should be available on a single
click with either graphical output in
forms of dashboards
and report output for final
documentation
let's now come to our summary for zero
effort analytical method validation
our goal should be to work as efficient
as possible
with the highest level of documentation
quality
data integrity is a core requirement
tools should be easy to handle and
integrated into your log workflow
with interfaces to all relevant systems
the proof templates for routine work are
mandatory
but flexibility and fine-tuning of
projects are necessary
tools must be validated and the
installation quantified
iq and oq in case
all these requirements are fulfilled we
have successful projects
and in the end we will get
detailed and comprehensive validation
reports
thank you very much for your time and
interest
in case you have any questions feel free
to contact me
thank you